young s'est excusé aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur ch quel saint jacques a
l'air très cool parce qu'on va créer des
pokémon voilà bon je vous le vend en
mode stylet mais c'est un peu moins six
à l'envoyer on est donc un voleur de
world of warcraft et on va pouvoir créer
des monstres comme lui il est totalement
répugnant je peux le frapper tiens et
s'il a vraiment l'air d'avoir mal bien
sûr que l'on dira monsieur patate
non c'est nous rejouer disney en vrai le
fait rire soutien appuyé au maire a
explosé partout partout après [ __ ]
mais c'est quoi cette vidéo non se plaît
ce mois c'est une blague
attention ça va péter à la faire
décoller la colline a des yeux fait
manges je te donne plein de mes regards
tout fout la paix maintenant aux bus car
c'était fatal ça c'est le coeur de
l'animal voilà on va pas recréer le
l'animal se c'est bon ça hop voilà
salaires extrêmement bien c'est nul et
short juste en train de faire un gros
bloc de merde voilà y'a quoi dans
l'inventaire jack en a plein de blocs en
fait
est-ce que c'est vivant ce qu'on a fait
ça bouge on a créé le premier animal qui
est aussi moche macabre et trucks et
martin winckler votre gazon anglais
c'est scandaleux on va créer la créature
la plus terrifiante qu'on a vues sur
youtube
ça c'est pas mal ça lors d'un début de
créatures faut faire plusieurs couches
d'épaisseur pour qu'un animal survie
face à ces prédateurs totalement faux
juste en train de justifier la mas de
merde que je construis foot ok ok pas
mal pas mal pas mal à temps est ce qu'on
va mettre des jeunes apportent tout ça
ça va être le devant des créatures quoi
mettre ça l'a fait pour deux yeux qui se
regardent de petites pattes de poulet
c'est terrifiant mon regard est
terrifiante
ah j'oubliais un truc important d elle
puisqu'elle peut voler cette créature on
dirait pas hop le petit musée aller
et au jeu tellement content on va
l'appeler bizarre youth je leur apprends
de vie et like hell qui l'a mouillart
c'est l'hôpital se déplacent ça marchait
on à dos des vieilles créa tion bordel
au direct qui souffrent de manière
continue franchement pour une première
créature c'est une réussite totale
on a rarement vu ça je t'aime bizarre
l'us open of my sur son dos ou pas moi
je vais sur son dos moi bon duo compte
sur puce a revu son nom pourquoi avoir
un cheval quand on peut avoir plus value
aux mondiaux ou du fait du rodéo ces
mots calmes toi mais a réussi alors là
je vais mettre tout mon coeur pour celui
là m'ont bien non on peut faire un arc
de cercle menachem pas fait ce matin il
devait trop puissance il a bougé un peu
foiré sur la fin mais ça le fait ça
l'fait olala c'est beau ce qui se passe
au gao c'est trop mal comme pat monga à
l'entente comme ça avec des pattes de
reptiles exceptionnel web et ses yeux
ici au progamme sur tout ce qui bouge on
pouvait les mettre des oreilles de
chiens on dirait le chien dentiste et là
je suis comme isabelle voyer mettre un
vieux bec tout claquer au plat ça secoue
à taureaux qui défèque sur mon terrain
là on vient de créer une horloge vivante
mon gars il aura débouche sur son corps
wallace le plus aucun sens c'est ce
qu'on fait là c'était style et jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant
bienvenue dans la non ce type zone obama
m des pics c'est ça sa manière de se
défendre mais voilà on dirait un
crustacé maintenant c'est génial ce
qu'on a fait est que cet animal on veut
le voir marcher il doit souffrir le pôle
dans la batée l'onho mon gars qu'est ce
que vient de faire
mais regardez le comme il est laid mais
comme il est laissé examen elle c'est
horrible on bien je marchais les
attentions au web apache et oui des fois
j'ai regardé comment il fait peur avec
ce coup là qui bouge comme ça aide-moi
bizarre trucs mais je voyage mais
l'année vous regarde sur ton corps
manche est d'accord donc il est vener
pendant toute la partie quoi à temps à
débloquer il ya un arbre je suis désolé
pour toi
alors qui sait comment on va pouvoir le
faire un serpent attention il faudrait
que je réussisse
[ __ ] on dirait du cornichon ça me
donne tellement fort non non non non non
j'ai pas fini j'ai pas fini j'ai pas
fini
crois moi j'en ai pas fini avec toi mon
pauvre
mesdames et messieurs laissez moi vous
présenter la créature la plus incroyable
que le monde ait connu
c'est un ami pat nouvelle génération
[ __ ] elle est déjà fatigué le pauvre
on pourrait aussi croire que c'est un
vrai rubik's cube comme il ya un truc
qui l'a tendu je voulais pas montrer ces
gens pètent un moment je vais me un oeil
sur les fesses et il s'est complètement
recroquevillé sur lui-même
j'en déduis qu'ils n'aiment pas trop
qu'on lui touche cet endroit là on a mis
un peu de crédit par des boutons avec
les très jeunes se montrent ian là il a
de l'acné on peut le dire alors qu'est
ce que ça donne bah c'était beaucoup
plus drôle justin pendanx si s'énerve on
y fait bon gars je retiens ça super bien
plus tard il est le père fouetter
semblant d'être faible alors qu'ambri
les super puissant il se met à nous
courir après comme ça maintenant je te
vois tu adoptes et même tuer bizarre ce
truc bien m'aider je suis tombé être ne
l'oublient pas qu'est ce qu'il fait sur
l'appareillage s'échappe lui le moche
lui mange mon mât créatures mais casse
toi mais mangent pas non plus que c'est
seul que j'ai pas créer mais dégage
arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez de vous
chamailler souple et mes bébés l'a12
l'arrêt d'ouvrir dès que tu as des siens
en vérité tout autant surpris mais il va
tout en ses mains des ça suffit à la fin
[ __ ] j'en ai marre bien et je suis
animateur dans une colonie d'un tarbais
quoi j'en peux plus sans déconner et
maintenant il faut une fête privée quoi
tous les cas dans un mètre carré alors
qu'à son mètre carré
ces 3 3 pour moi là et l'agencé
japonaise cette vidéo j'espère que vous
a plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude
j'adore puisque tous les jeux où tu
crées comme ça des animaux ou des
structures ont des choses et que tu en
fais absolument n'importe quoi c'est
juste génial je vais tout de suite
contacté nintendo pour que ces trois
créatures soit dans le prochain pokémon
franchement y'a moyen est en fait une
pétition sera pas salir serre aurait
gardé en se doter la fin de semaine
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien et à
bientôt
pis je me suis répété pis au qui
m'arrive